glückwunsch nachträglich liebe nato zum
siebzigsten diese woche die große party
in london
top stimmung und historisch gesehen
natürlich eine erfolgsgeschichte unsere
nato aber pünktlich zum geburtstag fehlt
leider eine gemeinsame strategie dafür
war aber donald trump diesmal kaum
verhaltensauffällig warum weil
frankreichs präsident makro die nato
vorher als hirntot bezeichnet hatte
hirntod das war heftig
so wie heftig nein das geht ja überhaupt
nicht die nato beschimpfen eine
unverschämtheit so was würde ein donald
trump niemals machen
es ist absolut nicht wahr jetzt obsolet
alt und fett zufälligerweise auch der
titel von trumps autobiografie aber das
nachsehen
übrigens wenn da nicht verhelfen
foto
übrigens hat immer neue völlig recht
diese nato ist sich nicht einmal einig
bei der wichtigen frage wer heute
terroristen sind erdogans türkei
nato-mitglied sagt die kurden von der
epg sind terroristen dabei haben genau
diese kunden geholfen denn erst zu
bekämpfen war aber trotzdem echt ne
super feier in london ganz toll nach
allem was man hört ja die queen hat für
alle schnittchen gemacht zwar super und
die un ihr abschluss erklärung dieses
nato-gipfels die es für mich gerade zu
kommen die gold da heißt das zitat die
nato garantiert die sicherheit unseres
territoriums jetzt kommt und die werte
die wir teilen inklusive demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit und hier kann man
direkt darunter eine türkische fahne und
zwinkert
ist wohl nato humor rechtsstaatlichkeit
ungarn ist übrigens auch nato-mitglied
aber dafür hat sich der laden muss man
sagen einen sehr sehr schönen imagefilm
zum siebzigsten geburtstag geschenkt da
sehen wir alle uniformen aus dem
gründungsjahr 1949 man marschiert
schneidig durch das nato-hauptquartier
dann 52 kommen die griechen und die
türken so von der seite rein ist
wirklich wirklich richtig toll gemacht
direkt danach wollten sie eigentlich
zeigen wie 1955 unsere bundeswehr dazu
kommt aber die szene hat es am ende
nicht in den film geschafft wegen
materialproblemen ja bei dem von der
luftwaffe ist leider ein schnürsenkel
gerissen
dann hatte ich wohne schuss aus dem g36
gelöst und bei dem dritten war das
nachtsichtgerät kaputt ja ja schade
übrigens übrigens sagt eine große
mehrheit der deutschen den umfragen sie
möchten sich nicht mehr von den usa
beschützen lassen ja wir deutschen
wollen lieber unter den französischen
atom schirm schlüpfen hier
kontaktanzeige verteidigungsministerin
in den besten jahren sucht ihn zum
geschützt werden gerne nuklear gut
bestückt apropos apropos wie läuft es
eigentlich gerade so bei unserer
bundeswehr
da ist doch zuletzt wirklich viel
investiert worden hier berichtet mal ein
deutscher kampfpilot das fängt ja schon
so an dass wenn wir auf eine flugshow
fliegen und alle anderen nationen ihren
kampfjet abstellen dann holen wir erst
mal dass panzer tab raus und dichten das
cockpit ab um es vor regen zu schützen
damit es durch die ritzen nicht
durchläuft ja da können wir nur beten
dass die russen uns nicht bei regen
angreifen
das wäre total unfair finde ich ja viel
geld für wenig qualität herzlich
willkommen bei ihrem zdf meine damen und
herren
schade
die bundeswehr ja
es ist wirklich schade ich hatte ich
hatte so gehofft dass der wechsel von
flinten uschi von der leyen auf ak-47
dass er endlich die dass er endlich die
wende bringt für unsere gebeutelte
truppe aber ja es klappt wohl noch nicht
so richtig sehr sehr schade
es gab noch nicht ernsthaft was ist denn
eigentlich unsere die deutsche rolle in
der nato
überall bin ich gefragt worden und werde
ich gefragt könnt ihr deutschen noch
mehr tun
ja wir haben es versucht wir können es
nicht sorry wenn wir wenigstens dazu
stehen würden dass wir es nicht können
oder nicht wollen
die groko diese regierung ist total
dafür die berühmten zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts für verteidigung
auszugeben wozu wir uns ja verpflichtet
haben aber wir machen uns halt nur nicht
circa 2030 wollen wir die marke
angeblich erreichen heißt es und china
weise genau das jahr in dem deutschland
seine klimaziele erreichen will ja du
das wird so geil 2030 das jahr in dem
deutschland alle probleme löst dann
funktionieren unsere panzer und sie
fahren natürlich elektrisch damit der
feindselig kommen hört ab 2030 werden
männliche küken endlich nicht mehr in
den schredder geworfen sondern nur noch
kastriert
dafür würden aber männliche ferkel
geschreddert 2030 gibt es nur noch
ökostrom allerdings werden die großen
windräder nicht mehr gebaut wegen der
anwohner klagen aber dafür bauen wir
überall indoor windparks angetrieben von
kindern
und abgehalfterte politiker 2030 wird
alles top denn mit dreißiger jahren hat
deutschland noch nie schlechter wartung
vom 8
ach ja
wirklich
die maschine alles für 2030 versprochen
wir sind auf schiebe weltmeister freunde
und bleiben wenn man beim letzten thema
bleiben wir beim thema klima denn diese
woche ist ja nicht nur nato gipfel nein
in madrid findet auch noch die
fünfundzwanzigste un klimakonferenz
statt
da kann unsere umweltministerin der welt
ja mal erklären wie genau man
energiewende total vor die wand fährt ja
darin sind wir nicht schlecht der ausbau
der deutschen windenergie ist klinisch
tot und jetzt hat der bundesrat unser
ohnehin zu kleines klima paket aber noch
auf eis gelegt weil die bundesländer
achtung angst haben vor steuerausfällen
ja wenn das so weitergeht fällt
weihnachten aus angesichts der schönen
tanne waren die kanzlerin dass der
klimawandel auch die wälder bedroht wir
wissen dass sie gut aufwachsen konnte
das ist für die zukunft für andere
tannen noch nicht gesichert frau merkel
schwänzt jetzt freitags wenn man den
bundestag und je zur freude des
propheten demo zurück zu recht was
dürfen wir uns genauer hoffen vom
klimagipfel in madrid wird schaut mal
live nach spanien zu bild es schneider
wird da wurden jetzt also wieder 25.000
teilnehmer aus aller welt eingeflogen
nur zehn wochen nach dem klimagipfel von
new york würden sie sagen es lohnt sich
gute frage herr wirken gibt es noch
hoffnung jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus
alle staaten werden alles was sie im
pariser klimaabkommen versprochen haben
auch tatsächlich umsetzen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich dachte ich steig nur mit einem witz
ein höher
selbst wenn die das machen würden hätten
wir eine erderwärmung von 2,9 grad bis
2100 aber wissen sie was das zieht
unsere zuschauer doch alles nur runter
wir können ja nicht ernsthaft unsere
ganze lebensweise in frage stellen nur
weil der planet x seine tage hat es
steht den menschen bis hier und deswegen
konzentrieren wir medien uns nur noch
auf das eine klima thema das spaß macht
kreta wo ist greta diese woche auf allen
sendern stundenlange live-schalten zur
ankunft von greta kreta tim berg wieder
in europa da sehen wir den katamaran auf
dem gerät attenberg es zeigt mir nochmal
größer
greta thunberg sollte eigentlich jetzt
schon da sein wir werden auf jeden fall
live mit dabei sein denn dort ist sie
auf der yacht von manchen wird sie
eigentlich auch erwartet wie so ein
messias von greta bisher noch kein bild
gesehen
sie scheint noch im inneren des
segelschiffes zu sein
ich drehe durch oliver musik kreta gar
nicht man sieht nur das niveau ist greta
unter deck auf dem klo was macht sie da
nervenzerfetzende spannung so geht
fernsehen unser zdf plant schon eine
traumschiff folge in der florian
silbereisen als neuer kapitän greta zu
den letzten eisbären in die arktis fährt
und heiratet was soll denn das ich habe
das gefühl alle reden nur noch darüber
wie genau eine einzelne 16-jährige von a
nach b heißt das ist doch gar nicht das
thema doch greta steht unter
dauerbeobachtung sobald sie auch nur ein
gramm co2 verursacht ist sie als
heuchlerin entlarvt und wir anderen
dürfen weiter fünf mal im jahr nach
malle fliegen oliver ich höre gerade wir
haben weltexklusiv erste live bilder von
genau der bahnstrecke auf der greta nach
dem gipfel von madrid nach schweden
fahren wird das hier sind jetzt also
tatsächlich die schäden auf dem sie
wahrscheinlich reisen wird übrigens auch
das original tempo faszinierend madrid
stockholm das sind normalerweise so 46
stunden problem sie muss einen teil der
strecke mit der deutschen bahn fahren
mit anderen worten heiligabend feiert
greta wahrscheinlich in der
bahnhofsmission von bielefeld das
interessiert doch keinen
im letzten jahr hat die welt über 55
gigatonnen co2 ausgeblasen rekord nach
24 klimagipfel darüber müssen wir mal
reden absolut oliver ich höre gerade wir
haben erste live bilder vom bahnhof in
bielefeld
in der pulsierenden metropole
ostwestfalens wird gerät attenberg den
geburtstag von jesus feiern wunderbar
was bei oliver vergessen sie alles was
ich eben gesagt habe greta hat ihren
plan geändert sie reist heute schon nach
schweden und zwar die ganzen 3100
kilometer auf einem elektro roller
wahnsinn das theater lithium batterie
die kleine umwelt so wird das schneider
meine damen und herren fehlen
[Applaus]